roland emmerich just just hates the
White House right because if you think
about it I mean you have independence
day where you blew it up and it's famous
then you you have to think that during I
don't know if they showed it the day
after day and tomorrow it must have
gotten too strong a must have happened
in twenty twelve and twenty toilet
must've been destroyed and in this movie
they just throw the whole [ __ ] thing
out and another going inside it ruining
it from there rolla never really likes
to destroy the white yeah he's just
bigger now he's like I can't keep
blowing it up what can I do send people
in there the [ __ ] it up for gun there
you go boom hi i'm ryan right i'm gerry
welcome to regions is she we give you
reasons to see and not to see why house
down so let's watch his [ __ ] review
reason to see number one Channing Tatum
I don't know how this guy does it sucked
one day and then before you know it he's
just cooler every movie was called like
the rock except whiter Channing Tatum is
the [ __ ] now he is just absolutely
[ __ ] cool as [ __ ] how many more [ __ ]
can you RAM in that I don't know it
plays this guy who is essentially like
John McClane the game you know like John
can ya know yeah they gladly talk about
in the interviews like how much they're
paying tribute to die hard so it's not
some coffee catheter actually saying
like know there are things we are doing
specific emojis to like Channing Tatum
like in the wife-beater yeah and like
him Union all bloodied up and [ __ ] read
the [ __ ] plot for crying out loud and
like how a lot of waters like hey John
why don't you call me dead I'm a Janeiro
Jacob changes so that I won't bore in
this movie I'm engineer he has so many
layers you know he's a very sympathetic
guy you can feel this guy's long and you
can feel his back so he's making real
three-dimensional performances this dude
and I think this is the first movie that
I've seen if I'm wrong like yeah this
dude's a [ __ ] star yeah well and I
mean he's
I really good blend especially in this
movie you know he can do the sort of fun
more light-hearted moments he can do the
sort of i'm a you know I'm a dad trying
to be there for my daughter moments and
then he can do convincing you know that
ass ex-military guy moments yeah so he's
got the whole package he came this movie
could do like all the different genres
he's very layered he's the dude is a
total [ __ ] star he's getting better
it's fun yeah each time right Channing
Tatum way to go buddy yeah good job man
I respected you're not just a pretty boy
anymore yeah wait here still pretty good
yea years you're still pretty [ __ ]
hot suck your dick reason to see number
two Jamie Foxx this dude was like Barack
Obama with what Jamie Foxx would do with
brock obama he sort of had like
caricature moments but they kind of fit
for this movie and they're the weird
kind of tongues it strikes he's
acknowledging yeah I'm a black president
in this movie because we have a black
president so there's a sort of sense of
humor that you can see that he kind of
has about it but at the same time it's
not like he just treats the movie like a
joke like he takes it seriously he does
a very good job in this movie he's funny
the why you don't him and channing tatum
are very funny together they have a
great back and forth like a really good
back and forth yeah i mean i really
enjoyed all the scenes they have
together you know where they're you know
fighting alongside each aaron and the
present florida how to hold his own like
they bring out the best in each other
grannies like tough situations that the
funny thing about this movie is it has
like a really cheesy sort of setup like
don't we have the best job yeah we are
Secret Service protects presidents
pretty sweet yeah you weren't there for
your daughter what you know what kind of
father are you gonna be ah you have this
terrible past when are you gonna learn
so it's all obviously leading down that
path but the way it's executed is very
fun to watch yeah they set up Jamie
Foxx's character like the man who's
never even been in the militant to
become a badass in topical relevant [ __ ]
and then at the same time you know
Channing Tatum he's gonna learn a little
something from Jamie Foxx to the two of
them to get out I wish I could make data
category Channing Tatum and Jamie Foxx
like there's the Channing Tatum category
the jamie foxx category and the Channing
Tatum and Jamie Foxx category yeah the
real reason this
number three reason to see number three
the bad guys so we can't give it all the
way for you because you know they're bad
guys and there's twists and turns but
there's a great ensemble here actually
you know what the whole supporting gas
is great yeah the whole support yeah
there are a lot of people in this movie
that I didn't know were even in it it's
like I had no idea that Richard Jenkins
was in this or that James Woods was in
this yeah when James Woods first showed
up I was like is is that a really old
James Woods kinda like Maggie
Gyllenhaal's and I had no idea yeah yeah
and then the Jason Clarke Jason kalai
didn't know he was in it oh where did
yall you guys come from like I'm so
happy that you're here yeah it's a great
supporting cast you know like all the
acting that's something I'm really
impressed me with this movie was the
cast was everyone was doing a great job
and you know d here like Roland Emmerich
and you think like oh another movie
that's just gonna care about like being
all crazy about the action and stuff
like that but he really knew how to like
bring a solid cast together who brought
you know their a-game to the movie you
got to know all of them to you really
feel like an act one not just like the
first 10 minutes like an act one you
really feel like you get to know all
these people they eat comfortable just
seeing what's going on before [ __ ]
starts getting crazy but that's what's
great is to connect to an action movie
where it's like yeah you're actually
connected to the characters especially
the main character yeah chani [ __ ]
tatum no reason to see number for
directing its cinematography I'm not
like like the roland emmerich hater that
like everyone else is I I enjoyed some
of his movies and stuff and you know I
thought he had a really good time with
this film why yes it's got a whole bunch
of layers there's a lot of action yes
there's like political drama there's
good twist there's good surprises
there's really good suspense but it's
funny like there's so much to it and
it's all shot really cool like the
lighting was excellent just the actual
imagery of it was all shot i'm like wide
angles the whole time yeah it really
makes you feel like you're in the White
House yeah that's right Oh big that is
which is cool yeah it doesn't feel like
they're just gonna set or a few rooms
yeah you really get the sense like these
guys are in the White House right now
there were times where I was like what
is the tone here because there are times
when its like people are shooting each
other and you feel the impact in this
really
and there are other times where it gets
you know like this banter heavy comedy
and then you have certain bad guys who
are like really whimsical sort of so
pretty I didn't get that feel like it
all sort of made sense I thought there
was sort of a humorous tone throughout I
mean there are scenes where it's like
yeah that's just a serious scene but I
felt like that in every scene they fell
like there was always room for a little
humor and that's how you feel I can't
judge you on that like I can't can't be
I feel differently but yeah I mean the
home boy knows how to how to put a big
thrilling action movie together and it's
you know shot well I was surprised i
forgot that this was pg-13 yeah I was
getting confused going to just read it
arms like this is a pretty hard each
other any movie like lots of people died
there's lots of guns yeah it's
definitely violin there is not there's
not like blood sprayed but there is some
there's blood at times you know [ __ ]
dwells I was sitting there and then the
pg-13 camp and I was like really yeah
yeah yeah like how did you talk your way
into that one yeah one thing I gotta say
is like there's a lot of movies that are
like replicates of die hard and this to
me is like one of the better ones you
know multi hard s movies this is this is
pretty good yeah it's a pretty damn good
looking it reason to see number five
action and effects but you know before I
get into the action what that gotta say
is what's so cool is like Channing Tatum
a prude kicking me an action star you
see him in like other roles or he's like
he's cool you know he's a badass he can
because of who he is rare is that role
for him or it's like no no that right
there that's that is what you wanted the
first GI Joe to do for you but this is
where it's really going down you could
be an action hero and gets his own
franchise and [ __ ] Marvel approached him
for something please but the action was
cool because it felt very actiony but
yet it was it has such a sense of
realism behind it not like too real too
because nobody can hit chain yeah yeah
there's that has its bulletproof but
there's also like the the fact that
people will eventually sometimes get
bloodied up and [ __ ] like that or you
you get to know a lot of these bag
cousin like Olympus is fond there's like
a shitload of bad guys and this one it's
like you kind of get to know a little
bit about each member so when they get
killed it's like all right that guy is
dead yeah
it's thank god he's out of there just a
few more to go now but it does not skimp
on bullets no not about hunches I
thought it was rated R just because I'm
on the spot it's a violent movie is a
very violent not like it's not like an
action movie that's just like I want to
call transformers violet but I call it
an action movie this is like a violent
movie it's not super bloody but like all
the sound effects and all the like
there's lots of bullets pray and people
clearly die like it's a hit a little
girl in the face some yeah they hold the
gun up to a little girl's head like 13
times or something though there are
hostages taken their fist fights then yo
people get blown up with grenades you
know but somehow it still manages to be
an entertaining fill it tows that that
balance between heavy action but still
popcorn fun there are moments you get
you really get this with an action
character but there are real moments
you're like way to go chanting boil them
and then that's also is there some cool
kills still there's some pretty sweet
I'm like that's how you take out a bad
guy yeah there's a real fear for
Channing Tatum a lot of the time you
know there's always a sense that they
couldn't lose in a way there's a sense
of Dean there's an actual sense of
danger when it comes to keep getting
higher yeah it feels very human it feels
like you know [ __ ] really could happen
to him that's bad you know he doesn't
feel like he's impossible and mr. badass
who's just gonna take care of the day
he's someone who really seems like he
has to be courageous and save the day
yeah it's rather than like something you
know cuz you said these action here's
where it's like okay bad guy not a big
deal okay you know ya like like die hard
5 is like I'm gonna kill everything yeah
exactly no one can kill me yet I'm gonna
kill civilians
the market gonna run all your over sorry
there's no jeopardy there are some
pretty cool effects like like how is
common Sierra Leone the helicopter shot
going through the city like that that
looks very real like a lot of the times
or it's like that has to be visual
effects this is great shot they shown
the trailer but the cars like flipping
through the air now that looks great
like I watch it like it looks very real
they obviously spend money Ryan's
consensus a great Hollywood action flick
is the reason to see white house down a
great Hollywood action flick is the
reason to see white house down yeah
Channing teams great the whole cast is
great solid scripts all directing those
are all the reasons to see solid action
Jerry's consensus fun summer popcorn
action is the reason to see white house
down fun summer popcorn action is the
reason to see white house down I enjoy
this movie more than I thought I would I
had a good time you know it's got a
little more to it than your your typical
summer fair and it's a lot of fun you
know go check it out alright guys thanks
for checking out our show why don't you
go ahead school that comment box below
and tell us which one's better let's
hear it olympus has fallen or white
house down and also after you're done
with that if you want to check out more
episodes of reasons to see click the
link right here and if you want to
follow us on Facebook you know like us
on Facebook click the link right here
and if you want to tweet us on Twitter
get it it's not really get a joke but
yeah I wasn't even a joke at all yes I
just needed it what thing was and how
you use it to ya click the link right
here you want to watch this movie if you
get that meaning and last but not least
if you want to get updated every time a
new reviewer videos out subscribe or
roland emmerich will blow up your home
you will yeah that's the power of your
house down your house down yeah I don't
know if there are we a Channing Tatum
here to save you or a small girl willing
to spout out lots of facts about your
house yeah have you seen the chance for
escape plan no what is that it's the
movie round it's the movies starring
arnold schwarzenegger and sylvester
stallone oh that movie that movie
I haven't I've seen the poster that
movie sounds cooler than what it looks
like it's gonna be got to get out no
reason I run the guide no prison oh god
Roger are you would like a vegetarian
that's it says in the luck it's his line
in one is like you read like the
vegetarian that's exciting you plays
like a prison gang leader in a way okay
I saw the poet's is something about like
two dudes in the most secure prison in
the world yeah I think like Rambo built
the place or something the character
ratios give up on most secure prisons in
the world because did cuz I never means
anything it doesn't matter good this
remember like lockout came out it was
like the most secure prison in the world
isn't even honor this I just got in
there pretty easily dad's trying to take
someone out yeah Escape from New York
this movie is different from from
Olympus has fallen wish I I thought
thank God righty I didn't hate that
women like their stuff in that movie
that works this movie is more
consistently good but you know I mean
that's gonna be the sequel is they're
gonna make the dryer Butler character
and the Channing Tatum character partner
that would be so that was so cool cuz
they were both badass in their own way
you know and there and and this movie
has the most presidents have ever seen
there are a lot of friends are a lot of
people becoming president in this room
yea though
you